last one schools
let's address that one how are you going
to fix the education future
schools so here's what i believe i
believe that
humans are entitled entitled to by 18
graduating debt free and with the
opportunity to get a career
that's what i believe but what do our
high schools teach today
the teacher geography and geometry you
graduate high school what happens maybe
you get a minimum wage job
or you go hundreds of thousands of
dollars into student debt that is not
how to lead a life
that is how to stay poor that is how to
stay broke especially in a state where
there's high homelessness
happiness levels go down and it's
difficult to get around because traffic
is so problematic and it's difficult to
build wealth because housing is so
expensive now don't get me wrong
california is beautiful and california
has so much potential we've got really
smart people in california
the leadership is broken and by solving
the leadership at our schools in
partnership with our unions
our school unions we can make schooling
better teachers
are miserable teaching the same boring
curriculum
seeing their students graduate at 18
turning homeless
or not able to get a job or working two
or three minimum wage jobs and then they
have a child
and then guess what now they're working
two or three minimum wage jobs and
they're in poverty and they're on social
services
that is not what california should be
fostering if that's exactly what
california is doing
we should be providing careers for
people because guess what happens you
have a career
and you provide lots of value to a
business because you have a skill
well then maybe you can get maternity
leave and you're not relying on the
government
the point is get people off rely on
reliant on the government
we got to get government out of people's
lives okay so that one i get it we want
people to get off of government
should we fire terrible teachers or
should we keep them keep tenure going
well i mean uh okay so this i think that
that goes into a
a very uh nuanced discussion as well but
i think
i just want to make this point here i
think we are on the same wavelength
of we want to get the government out of
people's lives
we want people not to be dependent on
the government but the way you
get there is by actually instituting
real change
and you do that with our homeless plan
you do that with our future we want
another 160 thousand homeless
people i didn't say that out of your
life
so let me ask you candidates running
against you no no
are you saying that homelessness is not
a state of emergency are you saying that
housing is not
it's about time you went on the
offensive good job but the
the idea and and that that you're
appealing to my libertarian nature
by talking about regulation uh the the
the
the way bureaucracy has has stranglehold
over
commerce okay these are all accurate
things these are things that i
that it's refreshing frankly to hear a
democrat and admit that this is true
but then you count out to the unions as
if they're not a bureaucracy that's
that's
harming the the uh the educational
process as well
and also we're talking about building
new homes and we're not talking about
the
government disincentive to build new
homes because right now
it's free money for section 8. the
reason that new homes aren't being made
is that you have these these uh
commercial real estate
these buy uh zoning the reason why every
city in america looks the same now is
because of government guys
the reason why there's shops on the
first floor and then apartments on the
next four floors is because of
government
this is how you maximize real estate i i
you go to i go to downtown europe
uh i love that i love having a coffee
shop downtown and people are able to
live above what's wrong with that
what do you mean i didn't say there's
anything wrong with it you're saying
that you're going to build more houses
there's a disincentive to build houses
because
right now if you have someone like if
you have patrick right and patrick's
going to invest
100 million dollars into a place he's
not going to invest in
in old school baby boomer you know
widespread suburbia
it's not going to be urban sprawl it's
going to be a commercial
section on the bottom and it's gonna be
three floors of section eight
and then three floors that you can put
out into a reit at three thousand
dollars a month and they stay vacant the
whole time he's gonna make
five times his money i i okay i get
where you're coming from
i do think a lot of government programs
create issues in housing such as such as
rent control and i'm not proposing get
rid of rent control
but i understand that rent control uh
actually disincentivizes available units
on the market so so there are some there
are some issues where rent control can
actually increase rents but we don't
need to talk about
rent control what we need to focus on is
more options for folks and guess what's
happening right now
because it's so hard to go through the
building and safety processes you come
into california with 100 million dollars
you want to build
a you know i don't know 20 30 homes or
something like that or you want to build
100 homes whatever whatever you can
build with your budget
you are incentivized in california to
build mansions
why because when you can build a house
for two million dollars and you can sell
it for five
it pays for all the headache and
nonsense you went to for two or three
years
dealing with the architects and the
building and the bureaucrats and the
regulation
we're not incentivizing actually
building smaller
lower end units because it's so
impossible and then it's not
profitable so it's actually i mean like
look we're on the same wavelength
i i just believe that these programs are
are coming in
uh making folks less interested in
providing so teachers
firebat teachers or keep good teachers
what do we do with bad teachers i need
to understand that a lot more uh what
what you're asking me
because i do not have all of the answers
and statistics for you on that
i think i personally believe that if you
suck at your job you should not be
working that job well your biggest
battle is the teacher's union and that's
where you've got to get
i don't believe that i am anti-teachers
unit i believe
that i am for a combination of
businesses working with unions and
non-profits
to provide better education we could do
that together
under the leadership of a government so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye